packed Hollywood Beach broadwalk turned
into chaos on Memorial Day sending
beachgoers running for cover after the
sound of gunfire rang out first 9-1-1
calls came in just before 7 PM after
reports of gunshots that started as a
fight between two groups video of the
moments after the shooting captured a
chaotic scene of multiple injured people
lying on the sand as First Responders
tended to their wounds
nine people were transported to local
hospitals including several children the
youngest just one year old police say
they have one person of interest in
custody but they are still looking for
another suspect